حتى هو انت قبل قليل وهو تاكيد فوز فترمان
بولايه بنسلفانيا هذه الولايه المهمه في
مواجهه محمد اوز اذا مشاهدينا نتابع معكم
ظهور النتائج اول باول يتحدث عن ولايه
بنسلفانيا التي كانت متارجحه حسمت بنسبه
للمرشح الديمقراطي جون فترمان كنا تابعنا
في الاطلاله السابقه احتفال جون فاترمان
وكانت نقلت وسائل الاعلام محليه وكالات
امريكيه بانه فاز الان تم تاكيد فعليا فوز
جون فترمن في هذه الانتخابات وبمقعد بمجلس
الشيوخ مع فرز
86% من الاصوات حصل حصل على
49.92 ونتابع في هذه الصور الصور المباشره
للاحتفالات التي تعم المعسكر الديمقراطي
في بنسلفانيا احتفاءا بفوز جون فترمان
الذي تعرض بالمناسبه لجلطه دماغيه قبل
مناظره تليفزيونيه مع منافسه محمه اوز كان
الفرق كبير ما بين جون فترمان ومحميه اوز
ولكن بعد هذه المناظره التلفزيونيه والتي
لم يكن فيها جون فتر مان موفقا استطاع اوز
ان يوسع الفارق بينه وبين فترمن ولكن في
هذه الانتخابات استطاع ان يحسم هذا المقعد
المقعد المهم جدا في هذه المرحله بالنسبه
للحزب همم الديمقراطي في مسيرته للاستمرار
في السيطره والاغلبيه في مجلس الشيوخ اذا
النتيجه